as the student I'm going to come up with
a problem formulation for the genome
sequencing problem to give to Alice
recall that the genome sequencing
problem is reconstructing a genome
sequence given the reads my problem
formulation would be in the form of a
well-defined input and output and as a
teacher I will guide him to reach a
formulation that is understandable for
Alice and also I will make sure that he
receives the output that he's actually
interested in so for my first attempt
what if I say that the input is
fragments of a genome and then the
output is genome is the genome given if
not you should mention that mm-hmm so
what about if the input was fragments of
some unknown genome and the output was
the genome it's good to avoid the
biological term hmm so what about if the
input was strings of an unknown
substrings of an unknown string s and
the output was that string s now
analysts can output any contract to
concatenate of input strings this is not
the output that you're looking for hmm
so now what if the input was a set of
strings and the output was immerged
strings that form a genome do you want
to impose any constraints on the output
because right now Alice can output
nearly any string as an answer to your
qualify emulation okay so what about if
the input was a set of reads and the
output was to construct an overlap graph
with vertices as reads and directed
edges representing overlapping reads
then we could find a Hamiltonian path in
this graph and that path that show us
the genome problem formulation is not
supposed to include a algorithm do not
provide an algorithm in your problem
formulation so what about if the input
the first line is some integer N and
then the remaining n lines are sequences
strings in the ACGT alphabet that are my
reads and then the output is a string
representing the genome problem
formulation should be independent of
implementation so you should not get
into the details of the format of the
data representation so what about then
if I rephrase it and said that the input
is just some set of n strings and the
output is a string representing the
genome
what does it mean a string representing
the genome since Alice does not know
what you mean by the phrase the string
representing the genome she can simply
output a concatenate of the inputted
strings to you
so what if now the input was a set of
reads where a read is defined as a
string form from the letters ACGT
and then the output is a set of context
where a contig is a set of overlapping
reads that together represent a
contiguous region of DNA we do not
provide definitions in the input and
output and if you can shorten your
problem formulation do it okay so what
if instead I define it before I give you
the problem formulation so my definition
I'll say beforehand given a set of
strings a contig is a set of overlapping
input strings and then my problem
formulation would be input is a set of
strings and an output is a set of
contexts
Alice can output any set of a string as
a context I'd given this formulation hmm
so maybe then instead I'll say that the
input is a sequence of strings called
reads then the output is a single string
in which all sub strings are a
combination of reads that contain
overlaps
for example AG ATT and AGA ATT are
combinations of a ga and a TT nee mono
the Phoenicians and examples in the
input and output now also given this
formulation Alice can output nearly any
string as an answer to your formulation
okay one more try let's see so what if
the input is a set of strings and the
output is a shortest super string of all
input strings that's better but the
notion of super string has to be defined
beforehand for Alice
okay so beforehand I'll say given a set
of strings they're super string is a
string containing all of them as sub
strings and then now my formulation is
as I said before input a set of strings
then output is a shortest super string
of all input strings that's great
so we were able to come up with a
problem formulation for the genome
sequencing problem in the case of
error-free weeds can you come up with a
formulation for the problem of
sequencing for error-prone reads
error-prone hmm okay so now if we have
errors in our reads
what if we change the formulation to
instead be where the input is a set of
strings s and a probability error pre a
probability of error P for each position
in the string and then we could say that
the output is the most probable super
string of minimal length that maximizes
the overlap between the suffix and
prefix of sub strings
well Alice is lost what is the
probabilistic model to compute the
probabilities and find out what is the
most probable super string so we're not
going to get further into the problem of
finding the problem formulation in case
of error-prone reads but to learn about
that be sure to continue with the course